[Music]
President Trump tweeted yesterday Daka
is probably dead because the Democrats
don't really want it they just want to
talk and take desperately needed money
away from our military well if they
don't get a deal protecting dreamers
Democrats have threatened to hold up
spending in the of course government
funding build and it's needed by
midnight on Friday to avoid that
shutdown so will the president call
their bluff
let's bring in Republican congressman
Sean Duffy and Wausau Wisconsin and
Democratic congressman Darrin Soto in
Orlando congressman Soto I want to start
with you and I want to thank you for
coming on the show and I want to tell
you that we make a real effort every day
to get Democratic congressmen on and
give them a fair chance just like with
Republicans to make their case I just
want to say thank you so thank you for
joining us Sean my thinking here Sean
I'm used to seeing you so it's fun no
I'm just kidding congressman soda let's
start with you will the Democrats really
hold up the government funding for a
deal for the daca people you know we're
hopeful that this is a moment where the
parties can work together we have Graham
and Durbin who have come out with a
bipartisan plan including border
security as well as help for our
dreamers and we're hopeful that the
Senate will lead the way and put a bill
out that will go to the House floor and
that speaker Ryan will give us an
opportunity to be able to vote on it so
that we're not talking about shutdowns
but coming up with a generational deal
to help out with two issues both parties
care about why do you think before we go
to congressman Duffy why do you think
that Durbin and Graham went into that
meeting with the two things that they
knew the president couldn't agree to it
would increase chain migration and of
course there was an adequate funding for
the wall I mean he said I need this in
this then we'll do the legalization of
the dreamers they came in and they
offered things that would actually make
it worse well I think you have to start
somewhere and then the president can
come back with what he perceives as
chain migration and make a counteroffer
on it and then there's the concern over
the wall you know there's not a lot of
support for the wall in the
Senate and you know it's controversial
in the house and it doesn't help where
I'm from in Florida we care about port
security and Coast Guard and other
things so you know I think you have to
put something out there to get a
response from the past I want to play
for you congressman Duffy something that
Bill Clinton said back in 1995 let's
watch all Americans not only in the
state's most heavily affected but in
every place in this country are rightly
disturbed by the large numbers of
illegal aliens entering our country the
jobs they hold might otherwise be held
by citizens or legal immigrants we are a
nation of immigrants but we are also a
nation of laws it is wrong and
ultimately self-defeating for a nation
of immigrants to permit the kind of
abuse of our immigration laws we have
seen in recent years and we must do more
to stop it with a bipartisan applause
that sounds like trough congressman
Duffy what's what's going on forgotten
like I I don't come on and say I agree
with Bill Clinton that often but I do
tonight Laura I mean this is this is an
easy solution I think it's great that
Darren's on here as well having a
conversation and it sounds like he wants
to get a deal but the deal that was
proposed is that Democrats get
everything where you give legal status
to dreamers and you give Donald Trump
10% of what he wants which is for his
wall I mean if we reverse that and said
well we'll just take 10% of the dreamers
they get a stay and get a hundred
percent of the wall Darrin would be here
with his hair on fire saying well that's
not fair let's cut a deal that works for
the dreamers where we secure the border
we end chain migration and we once and
for all deal with these kids Laura this
is about compassion and love and Trump
talks about this all the time and the
compassion and love of the Trump policy
is you give certainty to the dreamers
you and the next generation of beamers
because you have a wall there to stop
them from coming in but not only that
it's compassionate for America because
we stopped them the meth and the heroin
and the human trafficking and drugs that
come over and across our border so this
is a great policy that works for a
country for dreamers I think both sides
could cut a deal but you have Nancy
Pelosi who's out there right now saying
I want only dreamer legislation or a
clean dreamer bill and nothing for
Donald Trump that standoff leads us to a
potential shutdown
behalf of democrats that's wrong
congressman soto democrats are saying
some a handful that they're not going to
come to the State of the Union John
Lewis Maxine Waters others say Donald
Trump's a racist we're not going to
countenance in as president basically
he's not our president and they're not
coming what does that do to forge a
bipartisan deal on the dreamers or
immigration enforcement that type of
toxicity well I can't speak for my
colleagues I'll be attending and
bringing a in evacuate from Puerto Rico
who's now here in Florida to highlight
how we still don't have power down on
the island a lot of areas but I think if
the Senate can bring something over the
house then Sean and speak a ride and
others will have the opportunity to be
able to put their two cents in about
what they want and let's get a vote on
the floor on it but I think you know
we'll all be listening to the State of
the Union at least those of us who are
tending to see if there is any
reconciliation messager or any
additional input from the congressman
how do you reconcile I don't mean to
interrupt but how do you reconcile with
people who run out out of a meeting a
private meeting and they their effort is
to whip people into a racial frenzy
about Trump howdy how is that operating
in good faith Trump didn't shut down
negotiations he just said I can't I
can't do that and they rush out and say
oh that's the president's are racist I
mean how is that how is that gonna Forge
a deal that's just not good faith at all
well I think they were shocked about
what was allegedly said obviously no one
knows for sure maybe it would have been
better to just keep that closed-minded
but they felt the need to speak out
either way I think we need to get past
these distractions and go to what both
parties want which is help for our
dreamers help for TPS and help for
border security yeah and I think if we
can get something through the Senate to
the house let it take its course and let
a bill go under the President's desk and
if he doesn't like it he has the power
to veto it I think them a call
bill that Goodlatte bill I think that
should be the bill push that over to the
Senate why don't we do that I think the
house people have a have a better
solution but gentlemen it's great to see
both of you